[Music]
jim good morning how are you
dan i'm good um what is your costume
what's your halloween house i'm gonna go
as a hall of famer
like in what sport uh
radio
oh okay what what is that you go go as a
mic
no just going as myself like i'm just
going in as a hall of famer i don't know
did you ever have a good costume growing
up
no
mine were terrible bro
i mean we were we were into it we just
wanted to get out and run around the
streets and try to get some free candy
yeah so
we got to put some stuff together i mean
one time i think i went as len swan
that was because that was my favorite
athlete so i was lynn swan pittsburgh
silvered up helmet everything did you
ever meet lynch one
you know i did it was years later i
think i was in the league and i ran up
to him i'm like a little kid
but you know i'm like man i thought i
was going to be you when i was growing
up man it was awesome man but you're
growing up in ohio so you weren't a
browns fan you're a steeler now
you know it's funny because i grew up
closer to detroit
so actually the lions were more in touch
but not a browns fan not a bengals fan
uh
no i just it was something i think when
i was younger dan it was the colors the
black and gold in the 70s
of pittsburgh citizens since then even
though you remember the electronic
football game yeah that vibrated yeah
okay everything i had was steelers stuff
everything
have you gone to a game
oh yeah so i was at i was at three
rivers the last year before
they moved to heinz field to a cowboys
game
and then i went to heinz field for a
game so a few of my friends one i grew
up with played high school basketball
went to michigan state
played uh quarterback or safety
uh for the steelers
so i went to support him and then uh
another young fella nate washington
played receiver
was for the steelers from toledo and
went to go watch him and support him so
had some blood running through the veins
a little bit of uh toledo ohio guys
playing for my for my squad okay how
many shoes do you have behind you
bunch
okay if i said over under 100
uh over okay
what's the pair you're grabbing if you
gotta grab a pair
leaving the house
oh
oh that's a good one bro you know we
like to match the outfits up a little
bit now you gotta gotta coordinate a
little bit uh you know what actually
though it's a pair of slip ones that are
just these whites um
steve
jenniferkowski or something like that
nike that's just easy you just slip them
on and just go no style nothing else
just white gold everything any autograph
any autograph sneakers in there
no unless you want to send me something
you know all the favor yeah
you don't have any jordan autographs or
any of that stuff no no you know i do
have it you know it's funny i have a
jordan autograph picture when i was a
sophomore maybe junior in high school
they had a i was in you know ohio of
course and i was being recruited by ohio
state so they were playing at the old st
john's arena and it was a preseason game
dennis hopson was on the team played at
ohio state so they were playing i think
the cavs and i got a chance to go in the
locker room afterwards and i got this
picture with michael jordan uh after the
game which i still got is at my mom's
house that's the only autograph i got oh
well i think i got a doc muhammad ali
boxing gloves
yes did jordan remember giving you that
when you uh played against him
he didn't have a clue you didn't mention
that to him when you i didn't bring it
up either
okay help me understand this with lebron
james
he attempted six threes a game last year
that's the most in his career
in three games so far he's taking
ten threes a game and he's shooting 48
percent
when you get older
yeah you don't take it to the hoop as
much as you used to we've seen a lot of
guys vince carter became a three-point
shooter jay kidd became a three-point
you know is is lebron is this the
evolution of
lebron becoming an older player but
still a relevant player
yes
but you but you have to dan because you
can't exert that same amount of energy
and take that pounding as you used to
even though lebron is like
you know from mars somewhere and still
sub-human and what he does at his age
but you can tell
over the years that
the pounding
has taken away some of his athletic
ability especially when he sometimes
gets to the basket and can't finish as
well as he did in the past so
you know as a player you look at what's
the easier way for me to be more
effective but that also goes back into
putting in their work in the gym because
if you don't put in the work then that
viable option to step out and shoot
threes
is not there and you know that was one
of the questions in lebron's career
early on in regards to his jump shot
but as he's matured as a player
you know he shot
he has shot a a really good percentage
from behind three-point line but now is
more relevant and prevalent
because he is a little bit older
yeah i don't consider him a very good
shooter
but
like he's a scorer but he's accurate but
he's but he's accurate when you look at
the percentages of a three-point shooter
he's not a catch-and-shoot guy that
you're gonna spot in the corner and you
know he's gonna be not but
i tell you one thing for for a ball
handler uh what he's able to do when
guys go under the screen
and step back and shoot it
that is a weapon to have that a lot of
people sometimes don't have you know
what makes steph so good and kevin
durant not only can they beat you with
catch and shoot but they can beat you
off the dribble
so lebron being able to
handle step behind the screen come down
and shoot it off the dribble
i think keeps him viable and and active
and a threat when he has a ball in his
hand i've told this audience don't
overreact to anything whether no matter
what the sport is we we want to we want
to figure something out before
you should figure it out especially week
one you know the lakers okay they got an
old roster uh russ he's not really
fitting in oh you got dwight howard and
anthony davis pushing each other
i want to wait till after christmas and
then i'll get a better sense of how
healthy they're going to be what's the
workload like does russ know what his
role russ has never been like that
number three option
and and you go from being ball dominant
to what am i supposed to do
and i i don't think they're playing good
defense um i'm gonna beg i'm gonna let
everybody shoot for the most part go
ahead shoot those jumpers i'm fine with
that
what is your takeaway from the lakers
first week of the season
this is their pre-season because they
really didn't play the core group
together a lot of minutes in pre-season
now keep in mind you still kendrick nunn
is not in there tht
okay
um wayne ellington which changes the
dynamic of your offense because you have
a shooter so you don't have a full
complement of who the lakers are going
to be again everybody wants to overreact
in that first i don't care like you said
what sport but a lot of people just want
to be right and say well i told you this
team was not going to be that good i
told you this was going to happen i told
we know in in this league that 20 to 25
games you kind of figure out who you are
as a team now the outlier in that is if
you had some key players who weren't
healthy right away
that are just now getting back into it
so that
number of games may be skewed a little
bit more maybe larger because you got to
integrate those guys in to see who you
are but i just think for the lakers it's
a matter of getting guys on the same
page understanding rules i think russ
will be fine
you know the difference is is that he's
not a catch and shoot player that plays
with lebron but if you're the laters
what do you want
you want to be in a good position come
the second half of the season to be
healthy playing well and ready for the
playoffs whether that's you're in you
know you know in the fifth position or
third position
it doesn't matter i don't think to the
lakers they just want to be healthy
playing their best basketball
going into the playoffs
any issue with anthony davis dwight
howard having a little uh shoving match
well it depends on what it was about
really if it was more than that
for that to escalate over one play you
can question to say did it really just
escalate over you didn't switch on the
backside or is it something there we
don't know we have to keep our eye on it
but not yet now players get into it you
hate to see it dan know on the sideline
you know guys get into it and arguments
pushing matches in practice and stuff
all the time
but when it plays out on national tv on
the bench with those two players
that's when you know all eyes are like
okay what's the real issue and sometimes
it may be something as simple as a
miscommunication
or sometimes it could be some other
little thing brewing so hopefully that's
not the case
but it's not something that's an anomaly
to professional sports he's jim jackson
former nba great he is a clippers
analyst also fox analyst what did you
make of paul george talking to steph
curry
and saying during the game hey
let me shoot one from the logo i'll let
you shoot one from the logo
and steph they pick it up on microphones
yeah and steph shoots the three from the
logo and makes it
don't poke the bear just just leave that
one alone i mean some things you know
steph is going to do and i think paul
was you know
challenging from the perspective because
he's rolling at the top you know
the clippers are coming back but it's
some things it's just like
nah nah when when i actually play
against mike it's some things i would
say and talk
you know and then you know he'll give
you that looking next to you know he
goes off and that's steph too
steph may not look intimidating seth may
not talk a lot of stuff but you put him
in that situation then he's gonna make
you pay for what he did i mean i don't
know if it was the next play
he stepped to the logo
and knocked it in but but why would you
say something to michael jordan
jim well i mean because you know at the
time you didn't care i mean you were
competing you know what i mean you know
listen at the end of the day mike if he
gives you 40 or 50 so what he did that
to everybody i mean at the end of the
day you i'll be so it's like
i mean we were we were going back at it
in my when i was in new jersey we had
beat them myself sam cassell and that's
why john calipari was the coach we beat
them
in jersey and they were hot so we came
back to chicago and played and we were
drawing back and forth the whole time i
mean
just going at it and uh after the game
uh joe klein were walking in the line he
said man leave my young fellow alone and
mike said no jj that's my guy but tell
him that's why he's wearing my shoes you
know what i'm saying
look bike drop
drop yeah yeah you know what i kept
wearing it for the rest of the year
today
yeah m-i-k-e that kind of mic drops
oh definitely yeah i did have 33 though
that game so i can't we lost but i held
my home for at least one game um i'm
trying to figure this out with uh steve
nash's approach he said that james
harden has unfairly been the poster
child of some of these rule changes with
non-basketball moves he says he's still
getting fouled but feels the refs are
hyper aware with them when harden has
the ball
and uh he's
at the time shot only nine free throws
didn't steve nash
you know wasn't he the one that said
something about trey young and that's
not basketball the moves that he has and
now all of a sudden james harden's not
getting these calls what do you make of
this
well trey is not on his team that's why
what do you mean how many chances
are there so of course you got to go to
bat
you know for your player but listen it
doesn't matter for years james has been
able to get away to steph he's not
shooting the same amount of free throws
um i don't think luca or trey young this
year right now shooting the same amount
of free throws because they got to make
an adjustment the rules were one way as
a pro you make the adjustment i remember
they remember the hand checking rule
came in yeah and that was such
a different way of playing defense than
we were taught it took time for the
really great defensive players to reject
and they didn't like it they were
picking up files because that was what
they were accustomed to and no matter
what their reputation was about being a
great defensive player they were still
getting foul call but eventually
they were able to figure out that fine
line in between of how to bend that rule
a little bit and i do believe that the
the players that
are accustomed to getting to the line
drawing those fouls once they play more
games and figure out how the officials
are calling it
will be able to make the adjustments you
can't be mad now because for so long
you've been getting away with a lot of
stuff but not getting a lot of files
that probably weren't filed
so the tendency is to complain about it
a little bit but
pros will be pros and they'll figure it
out this was a conversation that was
brought up on this show when uh zion and
john morant coming into the nba and then
we saw them playing and i remember being
asked by uh one of my guys you know who
would you take and i said well i would
take john morant the basketball player
i'd take zion as the draw
because i i think you know zion's gonna
people come out to see him but i think
john morant is the better basketball
player long term
because of zion that weight um he you
know he's coming off foot surgery now i
mean yeah that and he's close to 300
pounds um
i i know it's easy to make the call now
and say john morant but
i i don't know about zion's bigger
picture here
and and you know how long can he stay
at a reasonable weight healthy yes
exactly yeah well but you know it's a
lot of people that are right now patting
themselves on the back that said at the
time that you they would have taken john
moran but it's all relative to the team
situation in new orleans they needed
that draw
okay at the time they had lonzo ball who
was running the point who they thought
in their mind
was very complementary to the team that
they had because um you know his passing
ability um
and
john i mean if zion if all things were
equal and he's healthy that's kind of a
once in a generation type of player
you know and that's not taking anything
from job because you can kind of find a
job moran in a draft and find a player
that can be similar from a skill set
from a scoring perspective you're not
going to find a zion williams you're
just not
okay now you want him to be healthy not
looking back at it oh i told you so what
no you didn't because nobody can predict
somebody's health now
they did have some caution some warning
signs to say that his his weight would
become an issue if he doesn't handle it
and up to this point he's not been able
to do that
hence not been on the court and john
right now has prospered and looks like
the better
player
long term because he's been on the court
yeah i love john moran oh i have well i
had the other day was against the
clippers i mean it's unbelievable and
you know the thing about it is
his level of maturity of understanding i
think
it kind of him like damn damn lower okay
cj mccombs small school steph curry
and now job for them to to be able to
mature over three or four year period
okay in school
learn the ins and outs
um kind of grow their gains
become one of those um i think um from a
leadership perspective they learned how
to lead
okay during their time so when they came
into the league
they were a little bit more mature a
little bit more game ready
and that second year for them you saw
this big jump because of that maturity
now
in college
you as you know as i know dan if you're
a senior you're washed up they look at
you like
you know you're not gonna grow anymore
but i beg to differ because you look at
john and this outstanding ability but
this in this is in between here where
he's really grown yeah now he's shooting
the jump shot a lot better it's gonna be
tough man
uh i think your last year you played 13
games with the lakers
mm-hmm no i sat
oh yeah i was there you didn't get to
play
i was there
did you did you keep your jersey from
that last season with the lakers
honestly you know
the 24 i have because my mom nicely
collected i probably would have threw it
away just knowing me just because i
didn't play but no i kept it because it
was i mean being part of the
organization of course the lakers and
you know i got to say that you talk
about being in the hall of fame you know
my jersey's up there hanging in the
rafters right now
which one
24.
yeah
okay
was well utilized while i was there
okay all right
so you're taking credit for kobe's 24
um
uh yeah
you know
coming into the year this is what i
heard though coming into the year he
wanted to change from 8 to 24
but that he had waited too late
because you know they'd already began to
market the number eight so that's why
the following year he had ended up going
to 24 and i i was able to get it while i
was there
so but i'm still gonna take credit for
it
hey great to take to talk to you and uh
we'll check in with you during the
season thank you jim you're ready go
bucks man all right that's uh jim
jackson
that's uh ohio state box not tampa bay
buccaneers uh former nba great and uh
basketball analyst for the clippers